not from around here no I I live in
Brooklyn actually hey youtubers is
charlie and Marvel just announced
they're making an ancient Carter TV show
based on the short film starring Hayley
Atwell she's not officially signed on to
play the role in the TV series but they
are releasing that short film with the
iron man 3 DVD next week on Tuesday time
with the agents of shield premiere so
what's really cool about all this though
is Marvel really seems to be developing
TV shows based on these short films that
they do every year after their big
movies so remember after Avengers they
had item 47 that was all about people
taking alien tech left over from the
Avengers invasion and using it to commit
crimes and how shield had to clean all
that up so obviously agents of shield
was born from that show now you have
iron man 3 this year and they did a
follow up with the Peggy Carter
character from the first captain america
film and now you have an agent Carter TV
show they're basically using these short
films as test beds for new TV shows
which is really exciting so think of the
show as like a spiritual successor to
alias or like the x-files it has a lot
of supernatural and sci-fi elements set
in this Marvel Universe but it's a
period piece so think Downton Abbey
crossed with sci-fi and it has a real
strong female lead like alias did and
will fit nicely with ABC's programming
right now they have a lot of strong
female characters like Kerry Washington
on scandal I think the fact that it's a
period show is going to really help it
out and just keep it under budget just
because they won't have to deal with too
much tech just like a lot of the modern
shows do and they won't have too many
superheroes or mutants so obviously like
in the x-men universe you have a lot of
people born as mutants and there are
super heroes like Captain America that
came from the 1940s but most of the
Marvel superheroes today are actually
born in the modern era so on the show
most of them won't haven't even been
born yet but let me know what you think
about the idea of an agent Carter TV
show most of us haven't even seen the
short film yet but I'm really excited i
saw a clip at comic-con and it's really
exciting so it's basically like a sci-fi
espionage spy show so think maybe like
Bourne films crossed with X Files it's
also really cool because it'd be the
first female Marvel character post
Disney to get her own TV show or movie
obviously I think a lot of people
expected Black Widow to get a movie
sometime soon but it looks like Hayley
Atwell is going to beat her to the punch
one of the other really cool things
two is that ABC and television in
general has had a lot of really strong
females recently like Emily VanCamp on
revenge she's also in a Captain America
movie next year which is kind of funny
small world Kerry Washington on scandal
and there's like Amy Poehler on Parks
and Rec so there are a lot of strong
female characters on television right
now so i think that Peggy Carter and
Hayley Atwell who will hopefully return
will just fit in really nicely with that
bunch so in case you're not familiar
with the character or you didn't pick up
on it in the first cast in America film
Peggy Carter is basically like a British
agent working with the precursor to
shield during the events of the first
captain america movie back in the 1940s
that's around World War two so basically
what happens is that she helps turn
Steve Rogers into Captain America then
obviously he gets frozen in ice and she
basically goes on to become a secret
agent with shield this show will
basically deal with that this show will
basically deal with her learning to
become a secret agent just to tie it to
captain america the winter soldier the
Peggy Carter character actually in the
mythology of this had a daughter named
Sharon Carter who also joined shield she
will be in captain america the winter
soldier as a SHIELD agent working with
Steve Rogers there have been some rumors
that they're supposed to have a romance
in the film and that she might even be
the red skull secret daughter sin but if
that were true then none of the
backstory about her being Peggy Carter's
daughter would be true so based on the
amount of time it took for item 47 to
air and the time that agents of shield
is premiering is totally possible that
we could see an agent Carter TV series
premiering alongside agents of shield
season 2 next year in 2014 obviously ABC
would want to piggyback on the success
of agents of shield hoping that'll be
massively popular which I think it will
be like I said agents of shield is
premiering next week I'll be doing
review videos for each episode be sure
to subscribe to get them and don't
forget there's a ton more TV shows
coming back this month and in October so
there'll be a whole lot of TV on my
channel real soon and just because you
guys have been so awesome and help me
get so many subscribers so fast I'm
doing a special Sherlock themed giveaway
for when i hit 25,000 subscribers i did
a video explaining it right here you can
watch it or if you see that already you
can click here to learn about all my
other recent Marvel news thank you so
much for watching you guys are awesome
high fives
you